today I would like to tell you about I
would like to tell you a story about the
most reclusive a place on earth my home
country of North Korea in this length of
fear and desperation three generations
of family still can be sent to a labor
camp for the most ridiculous offenses
like some simply tries access outside
information and see the outside world
out of the Hermit Kingdom as a child
growing up to the tiniest Nick the
Chinese border I was lucky to receive
outside information and one day I
decided to take risk and journey into
the great unknown as a curious high
school student who lived simply and
quietly under the Qing Dynasty I could
have never foreseen the drastic changes
in my life during the follow those
dramatic steps across the border now
more than fifty years later at an epic
journey and for over hardship and
triumphs I am here to share my story
with you and the lessons I've learned
from the moment I was born I was fed
propaganda and I viewed the Kim family
dynasty not only as our fearless the
protocols from the imperialist forces'
but also as God's Guru you know I never
thought our country's founder Kim his
son could even go to the bathroom like
as humans
it wasn't until age 14 when I saw his
funeral I realized he was actually human
until the moment I thought our God can't
die using elaborate deceptions as well
as cause with tools of control the
logical leaders was able to indoctrinate
embryo was purposed the majority of its
citizens depriving them of the natural
right to learn that truth about the
outside world
most people can't understand why no
screaming people are crying at the
deformity Tareq's Kim II sung and Kim
jong-il died but those who grew up there
we completely understand that the first
to learn to say mom and dad when you're
young children and then say thank you to
our beloved leaders previously when I
taught there were cards I didn't think
it was a strange just as eating three
meals a day was normal so I thought
going to their pictures and singing
their praises was also know me as a
North Korean we can't say bad things or
complain about the leaders and we can't
call their name exactly without putting
any specific attires and we can't have
exactly same name as the leader so even
if an old man was called kim jeong-hoon
for his entire life but now he must
change his name most Koreans are
constantly inundated with anti imperious
the propaganda especially against
America from the kindergarten we learned
that the Americans are our primary
enemies who killed many innocent North
Koreans during the Korean War so even
these days North Koreans learned that
Americans are colonizing North Korea and
executing South Korean students so our
hostility towards Americans were so high
and we considered that they are not as a
normal human being so they're the person
who must secure them off we also learnt
that British are considered gentlemen
North Korean Americans are bastards
we really never learned why British are
considered gentlemen and so therefore
every schools we had all the schools we
hang posters about killing American
soldiers and a bear on Children's Day we
played a game about how to staff
American soldiers not north Quixote's
demand complete loyalty and submission
to the system and those who refuse are
considered enemies of the state and they
are suffering horrific human rights
abuses for example there have been on
numerous cases in my hometown where
entire family disappeared after in the
middle of the night one of the family
members complained one of my friends
fathers said simply to his best friend
this is his time it's unfair he was a
sent to a political prison camp while
his family was removed forcibly removed
for desolate and mountainous areas where
it is extremely difficult to survive
many people in prison camp they even
didn't know why they were sent there and
they are completely stunned when they
are dragged out of their homes and
thrown into prison meaning their lives
forever
we also have mandatory self-criticism
sessions which we must criticize our
friends and neighbors and classmates in
addition to the numerous snitches and
informants paid by the government so the
system comply completely destroys the
trust within society and even between
husband and wife because after they
divorced one person could kill to the
government about the other person's
behavior anyway you may compare this
situation to the studying is the Germany
where in a while find out the epidermis
reunification what the her own husband
was spying on her the entire time in
North Korea and estimated
hundred thousands of people in prison
camp and one of one of the my distant
relatives actually experienced this
horrible fate in North Korea he came to
North Korea during the 1970s from China
and he thought North Korea was going to
be a communist utopia as the North King
government advertised but after that he
realised the advertisement was not true
and she decided cross back into North
Korea again but unfortunately he was
caught by the border guards and he was
sent to the prison camp he was sentenced
to 30 years and his son was only a baby
at the time after he grew up he pitted
the several times to see his father in
the prison camp but every time he was a
teen I to access his father never freed
and eventually after he died his son
even couldn't retrieve his body for a
proper burial I also witnessed my first
public execution when I was a seven
years old I was a stunned to see a crowd
gathered around a man hanging from a
bridge the Moscow authorities wanted
people live in a constant state of fear
so they forced us towards public
executions so sometimes the schools
canceled the classes so all the students
could have witnessed the public
execution and attendance was mandatory
sometimes people were even executed for
very minor offenses such as a man who
stole one kilogram of grain from the
farm to feed his starving family lost
the authorities often imprisoned those
for trying to escape or make money in
China to support their families back
home yet supposedly sorcerous the system
provides no support and forces people
into miserable life of poverty and
hunger even though the people who saw
the public execution were usually
terrified we accepted the
execution as part of our life or America
since we didn't know anything about the
concept of human rights
so the executions were a constant
reminder that I still do anything to
disobey to our government ultimately to
be the killer in North Korea is a
starvation which has killed more and not
more than a million or scam people by
middle 1990s
I started notice that people around me
was suffering one day in 1995 I went to
my friend's home during the lunch time
after the school but the family didn't
even prepare anything for the lunch so I
complained to my friend
that whenever she came to my home my
family fed her meals even snacks so I
thought their family were very stingy
she reluctantly to me her family's
kitchen and showed me a part I had
barely anything inside of it I was
stunned and still I don't know what was
the inside the exact arriba I was kept
thinking at the time myself this isn't
food for human why don't I have a longer
food but few months later I discovered
the answer when I read when I read a
letter from a woman about her whole
family was dying because they didn't
have any food for weeks they had long
energy and no hope so the five family
members were lying on the floor together
and waiting to die I was so shocked this
was the first time I heard that people
in my country was suffering my most
vivid memory from the family was when I
was so a lifeless woman lying on the
street while an imaginary child in her
arms just stared helplessly his mother's
face I was so sad and I placed some
money in the child's lip but I knew it
wouldn't last
at that time when I saw so many people
dying and begging on the street I began
to thought them
country's propaganda the north grace the
best in the world we were always taught
that the capitalism was a sickness that
would cause society decay but I didn't
say how communism could be better when
people dying and begging in the street
even our teachers had started teaching
so they could earn a little money from
the market still at the time I didn't
know that we was suffering due to our
governments food system and I believed
that there was in the propaganda that we
are only suffering because of Americans
sex sanctions and oppressed our leaders
to protecting us and doing their best
for us fortunately information from
beyond the regime's control would soon
help open my mind since I lived right
next to Tiny's border and amazingly our
television could pick up a few tiniest
TV channels and as I watch the secretly
I became overwhelmed with curiosity and
for over dreams about the outside world
although even watching TV was a problem
because of a constant power shortages
and night sounded by darkness and
poverty and starvation
I often cased across the river at
China's brilliant streetlights
and new signs and I gradually realized
that my country is not the best in the
world I have been lied to hold my life
after this revelation I was determined
to leave North Korea to find out the
truth about the outside world for North
Koreans trying to cross the border is a
huge risk and some people die trying
border guards will shoot to kill and
sometimes I saw that bodies floating
down the river during the famine luckily
my family had some connections to the
border guards in my area so it wasn't
hard for me to cross the border at all I
could have never image I thought I could
quickly come back from my journey to
China yeah I could have never imagined
they're able to take 14 years until I
would
my family again after arriving in China
I began to learn truths about my country
and I was stunned to learn that all the
history I belonged was for over
propaganda most importantly I realized
their life of fear hunger oppression is
a crime against the Norseman people
although I began to get a sense of
freedom in China I was also terrified
since the Chinese government were
captured and repeat rate North Koreans
or talk back horrible fate back in North
Korea so even in China I wasn't really
free after three years of living under
the radar someone eventually reported me
so I was taken to the police station the
interrogators were grilling me for a
long time and forced me to read the
difficulty Chinese newspapers I acted
calmly on the outside but inside my
heart fit it was like like going to
explode
if I fit to convince them that I was
Chinese my family and I will be enthused
to trouble thanks to the countless hours
I spent studying Chinese at the time my
Chinese language abilities were good
enough to answer those difficult
questions and read the papers afterwards
seemed to like eternity one officer said
for another this was a false report
she's no North Korean and then let me go
it was a truly a miracle I just quickly
decided to move to Shanghai since it's a
big theory and without many no scanty
factors so it would be difficult for the
Chinese ports to find me
so in Shanghai I started a new life
again and with all my hard work I
purchased Chinese ID cards and
eventually I was able to get a job at a
trading company at the tales of living
and struggling in China I decided that I
wanted to see the differences between
the North Korean propaganda and
life is so screwed with my own eyes so I
got a piece out to South Korea in 2008
in South Korea's Incheon International
Airport I asked for asylum and two
officials approached me and they take
them my documents closely and they asked
me with the suspicious eyes your Chinese
passport and visa
arere are you really a North Korean they
thought I was a Chinese citizen
impersonating North Korean to receive
such gained citizenship so they want me
to go back to the Shanghai to the next
airline is I will receive strict
punishment under law law and then be
deported
I couldn't believe in even in South
Korea I'm in danger of being repatriated
to China and then be to North Korea
where I might be tortured and publicly
executed for being for pigeons to South
Korea those who are racing through my
mind was this all like was this old
mistake that I came to South Korea after
a long investigation in national
intelligence service that lasted three
monsters I was finally accepted as a
North Korean and I was finally released
into suspense society6 most after I
first arrived my first day as a
sovereign citizen there was a huge
burden for me to adjust another new life
again
but I was still very grateful because at
least I have a citizenship a place to
sleep and assistance from the government
in China I started with nothing and I
worked my way up
so I reassured myself I could overcome
this difficult time but settling down in
South Korea was a lot more challenging
than I had expected North Koreans and
South Koreans look similar on the
outside but inside will be changed due
to more than 60 years of division
throughout this time or lifestyle
and culture human languages have become
different and North Koreans have to
endure press this and I see stares from
some source Koreans so many North
Koreans try hard to hide their
identities especially when they're
looking for jobs after many years of
hiding my identity in China I was hurt
and disappointed that I need to have to
hide my identity identity again in
motherland too
in the end I went a serious identity
crisis and another surprising aspect of
life not in South Korea was that I had
to face yet another language barrier I
already experienced a language barrier
in China but I could never imagine today
English would be so important in South
Korea so I had to start learning my
total language while studying for the
university entrance exam suddenly one
day everything changed I heard that my
family in North Korea had a serious
problem by the government so I had no
choice but to risk my life by helping
them to escape I went back to China and
I secretly raided my family on the
Chinese border with North Korea after 14
years I would finally see my family for
the first time in person
my mother had faked her own base and
paid the doctor to forge the death
certificate while my brother used his
connections to the border guards to get
them across when I finally met them on
the poor Chinese border with North Korea
I was really excited
well we couldn't even embrace each other
for fear of getting caught
so until we got to the hotel we didn't
say any word after we were finally safe
in hotel I was so sad because my mom
other looked beautiful they were soaking
wet and shivering and especially my mom
looked very old she told me that stress
was almost unbearable we couldn't stop
crying and hugging and stay up whole
night to talking and I told them for
details over my plan we would travel
China by bus and then cross border into
Laos and then seek asylum in Sasuke
embassy we stayed a few more days so
everyone could regain or energy but we
didn't have much time to waste
we had a long journey ahead of us the
day we choose to depart was a horrible
day and at the time I didn't know that
it was a time as National Day so there's
a huge Chinese police presence checking
IDs on all the bosses within the first 5
minute apart depart departure or post
was stopped for the inspections the
military soldier reported and he
starting checking IDs while he's looking
at its passengers eyes in the eyes
I couldn't believe or better look my
brother he was only unfortunately he was
the only male passenger on the bus at
the time and she was also stood out
since his dinner he has he was dinner
and he had a darker skin colors compared
to the other Chinese men hitting his age
because North Koreans we never used any
Sun cream and he pretends to be asleep
right so the surger working dracula -
towards my brother my heart pounding was
so fast and I myself I found myself in
panic I knew if I don't do anything in
that situation you will not probably end
where I had to do something but what I
froze and my heart
and my body turned stones as the soldier
approached and I was kept asking myself
what can I do what can I do
the card was so close now and just a few
more steps left and suddenly I found the
answer and some time in front of him and
I put the cameras in his face and I
started taking pictures of him he became
he was a stunned and I started taking
more pictures of him and I and he became
furious don't you know it's illegal to
take pictures in this kind of situation
he did in Chinese so I gave him innocent
smile and I said I'm sorry I didn't know
it's illegal since I never seen anything
like this before I would delete them
right away and every passengers on the
post was staring at us beating him and
he was flustered and turned around and
she ran off the bus I was so relieved
but the long and difficult journey had
just begun after the long of a Pettifer
step aside we took a short break and we
started another long bus ride they would
take between 16 to 18 hours again on
post was stopped a old later after the
departure this time there was a Chinese
police officer he demanded all the time
all the passengers ID cards and even he
castling names and asking asking
questions like where is your hometown
we're all going and while you are going
there like this it's obvious he's
looking for an oriental [ __ ] my heart
sank even though my mom and brother has
the Chinese ID cards that I borrowed
from some Chinese but they can't speak
Chinese at the time so
so my brother's our fake name was called
the Tennessee police officer demanded my
brother to come up to the front to meet
him my brother just froze and I noticed
his face completely dark it was like
nothing I've ever seen like this before
he called my brother's name second time
and then a third he was clearly annoyed
and I just pushed on my brother to get
off but I saw my brother was shaking
with the fear it was really hurting me
at the time so I spring into another
action once again I taught a police
officer his step and dump and I'm a his
chaplain he looked at me with suspicious
and in disbelief as I was just trying to
explain I heard grunting noise behind me
it was my mom pretending to pretending
to be mentally talented a person she's
with me too I said she's also deaf and
pump I thought a police officer he
looked absolutely shocked and after an
awkward silence
he morold it there are too many deaf and
dumb people on this bus
and she turned around to the bus driver
and ticket checker he asked is this true
and those four person was visibly
annoyed by the long delays and quickly
assured him that he was indeed true
reluctantly in disbelief he cut off the
bus and we started moving again and my
family and I returned to our seats every
single passengers was staring at us at
that time I occurred to me actually my
family and I had been talking Korean the
entire time so every passengers in the
post they know that my mom and brother
went deaf and dumb but amazingly they
didn't say anything it was another
miraculous moment in the journey and I'm
so thankful to those passengers that
they didn't expose us so for the rest of
the journey three awards led in silence
and even after the bus ride right over
thus overcoming overcoming stress made
us too difficult to talk each other
after the truth advertising to fuse
bullets on the previous right I decided
to quickly move to the last part of the
journey and we to get another bus to
sauce now we had traveled more than
thousands of kilometers from the
snow-capped mountains of northeastern
China into the subtropical heat source
is the China as we approach the near the
border we feel a growing sense of
excitement since the end seem to be
seems to be inside
however the journey and hit had taken
its toll and three of us lost a lot of
weight and couldn't
with the scorching heat or energy was
nearly depleted when we finally pulled
into the last bus station near the
border I had a rest for the brokers so
he could take my family to the into the
loss since I don't know the way I met
him at the last post station and we said
our goodbyes and I told my family I
would see them soon back in South Korea
I reassured them and exhausted we parted
aways in the next morning I took a taxi
I thought my job was done but just as I
was approaching to the airport
my cell phone rang your family was
caught at the crossing the border into
Laos and they are probably taken to the
prison in Raanana
it was a broker wrong what I asked I
never even heard what the Laos until I
started planning this journey and
certainly I don't know anything about
the country he said in the past the
captured reality factors were taken to
their and it's about 40 kilometres from
inside from the border and she said he
couldn't hear me anymore and he just
hung up the phone my head started
spinning and the energy shipped all over
my body and I slumped into the seat
immobilized by hopelessness and I told
the text driver turn around and to go to
the border area not knowing where to go
and I asked some random people for the
directions and finally what worked the
border areas of law immigration building
looking to the mountains around the
border I was guessing I was trying to
guess which mountain my family had
crossed because I wanted to have some
kind of feeling to connect that they're
still still near me I was a kept looking
at the mountains and I was trying to
connect my brother and my mum to Seoul
and I couldn't stop thinking if I would
have a chance to meet them again in my
lifetime maybe their souls were lost on
the mountain that day finally I work to
cross into the immigration line and I
noticed a tall white man was standing
behind me and we took a sample to the
rural Nanta but I didn't pay any
attention to him
little did I know this man would soon
change my life after arriving in ranpur
I spent four weeks between going back
and forth between the law immigration
and policy station to desperately trying
to negotiate my family's release I
bribed them every days but the
authorities wouldn't release them and
one day after many days later they told
me if I pay a fine per person with the
US dollar then they can release my
family at that time my cancer was
running very low because already I
borrowed two eyes from a friend in South
Korea
I just went to coffee shop to think what
to do but I couldn't find any good
options I was so depressed and the whole
world seems so dark but luckily a bright
ray of sunshine came into my life when I
needed it most
excuse me are you a traveler
I just don't wonder the people lives
staying here for a few days bah
I saw you a few weeks ago he was the
tall white man from the bus I only knew
little English and even though I
couldn't completely understand him but
we started communicating with my
cellphone dictionary after he heard my
story he looked quite surprised
and he made a quick phone call with his
friend and he told me he would hear me I
couldn't believe what I was hearing
why all the tourists renzobbi help us
like this so many people in my life had
been deceitful and manipulative preys
away for me here he said I wasn't even
sure if he would come back
but soon he came back with a fistful of
cash by the way my name is dick then
then he hit me I even didn't know I
didn't even he hadn't even know his name
eventually we went to prison together
and released my family and three other
North Koreans to be freed from the same
prison my mother first looked at me in
disbelief and then ran like the wind to
embrace me she was sobbing and awful she
looked very awful but at least we were
together again after that I decided to
apply to pay some poorest officer
so we could get a ride to a capital of
Laos without being stopped but
eventually we were betrayed instead of
taking us to the saucepan embassy they
handed us to offer some security
officials for arrested in my mom and
brother once again then sternly I was
interrogated accused of human
trafficking for merely trying to help
North Koreans reach safety and I ordered
it to pay another vine deficit in Laos
were exploiting us in every way possible
I finally resolved the issue five even
more borrowing from a friend in South
Korea and I had to leave the country
immediately while my family rotting in
prison for another three months s and
followed by three more months is really
in
embassy after my finally my family
finally arrived in South Korea they had
to spend a total of six months in
interrogation center and educational
facility so in poorer I had to wait a
full year after living loss until I
could finally meet them again after
arriving in South Korea I thought about
the kind of trillion men Allah after he
paid fine for my family when he found
out that I didn't even have enough money
to go back to South Korea so even he
paid my Atlantica at the time so I
thanked him with all my hurt and I asked
him why are you helping me
I'm not helping you he said I'm helping
no skinned people his good deeds changed
my life completely before me him I don't
the whole world was so caught me but at
the moment I realized that the life is
still worth living and I believed the
engines not only enables or movies that
they're working among us it was a huge
realization for me and because of his
actions I got to where I am today
unfortunately we lost the contact after
lip gloss but amazingly he saw my paper
last year so he was able to continue
once again so we were eventually
reunited on an Austrian TV show and we
are still talking to each other these
days North Korean refugees have
experienced a lot of pain
and we are sometimes awkward in the
outside world since we live to such a
share of their lives and posterior doing
our best to laugh and sometimes at
ourselves one time on North Korea visit
friends she started eating an unpeeled
banana in public since she never said
anything like that before
as everyone around her was stirred and
stopped she feels so embarrassed
but now it's a funny joke between us my
mom also had some funny moments since
arriving in South Korea the very first
day of freedom in South Korea my mom and
I went to ATM to withdraw some cash to
buying some crude but she just stood
stood there and she's staring at the
machine for a while so I asked my mom
and mom what are you doing and she said
I can't understand this machine how is
the money counted so fast and how even
the worker fit inside the little man has
to work there all day and even without a
window I just the first are laughing and
I told her this was the machine and
there's nobody inside we can only laugh
about this kind of incidence because it
helps us to realize how ridiculous life
in North Korea has to really become but
sometimes we wondered if how different
life would be if we were born somewhere
else
while I was living in China I was always
told if I would have been born in there
it would be 100 times better than living
then living in North Korea even though
China has many problems but the
situations compared to North Korea much
better and for the average the life is
much stable but since we couldn't we
can't choose our parents when my mum
pers gave it to me and I first opened my
eyes I saw my fate was grew up in North
Korea in reality calmness or the North
Koreans are suffering simply because of
the sin of being born in North Korea but
looking back due to that adversity I
became more matured and learnt many
virtues
wisdom strength and bravery I didn't
feel angry whenever I encountered
hardship that I couldn't change instead
I lived my life overcoming obstacles and
dealing with adversity instead of
complaining because I realized I
couldn't tense the situations in front
of me but I could only determine my
response and that has been very
empowering it's an epic it was an epic a
epiphany to realize that the constant
obstacles in my life were not actually
blocking my road that there are showing
me a new path so I urge you all to truly
appreciate the country where you're born
and the opportunities you have and
gathered here in this beautiful facility
clearly we have all been given much
therefore much is expected with us so we
may find somebody in need length let's
lend a helping hand and because
Samaritans using our talents to make
this world a better place I finally I
hope you also remember when if you
encounter on her or obstacle don't think
of it as an obstacle arrow think of it
as a challenge to find a new path on the
road less traveled thank you for
listening
thank you so much for sharing your story
we really appreciate you being here
we're now going to take questions from
the audience
Ryan and Michael are going to pass
around microphones please stand up
introduce yourself very briefly and also
please take into consideration Hansa is
a non-native speaker so please speak
slowly and succinctly thank you very
much for speaking to us my name is etem
myanmar was a simile always a very
oppressive regime as well and in the
last sort of five years Myanmar has
changed a lot
do you see hope for North Korea in this
case it's hard to compare any like an
[ __ ] or China or Germany situation
because uh North Korea is a completely
different situation because the North
Koreans are the most prone as the people
in the world and what was the cause
yeah there's a even though North Korea
is a really Luke reciever country but
still it's changing the society because
of because of the young generations when
our parents generation so they are more
believing the what government says but
the young generation which is my
generation because of the lot of
information flowing into North Korea
from the border areas like a sauce
canned dramas or movies and musics it's
helping to change their minds but still
it's hard to say that societies because
of this we can't see the huge pictures
for that even though the young the
emergence of young leader Kim jong-un
and even though younger generations in
the society their activities we can't
all see the differences because all the
high-ranking positions offices are from
the older generations so after they
changed replaced from the younger
generation then we can hope for some
changes but not yet that's my answer I
thank you for coming today my name is
Yemi I just wanted to find out what do
your family what jobs do they have right
now in Korea and also you mentioned
difference or Square in South Korea and
you mentioned that it's difficult for
people come from North Korea to get jobs
in South Korea so I'd love to know what
jobs do most of the North Koreans who
announce South Korea do you know even
North Koreans are in so screw Richard
sampler we consider the one country but
obviously we are terrific as a refugee
you know it's a tip even as I said in
the specific looks similar on the
outside but inside we've changed because
of the long separation so especially
when it's the same as different other
countries refugees so North Korea
situations is
I'm in so screw this they can't find
because nice it's not because especially
North Koreans have a lack of education
from source in North Korea because we
didn't have proper education or not
important the top skills and they
believed completely like a communist
system and then when they asylum to
South Korea which is a 70 years gap and
then there's a capitalists from
communists from capitalist system they
moved to one time and then the economic
gaps we can even measure in a hobby so
and the in North Korea people they don't
have they don't have own decision to
make a decision living in stores in
North Korea because always government to
tell them to what to do you do this to
the blah blah blah like that so but when
we when they move to South Korea there's
nobody's just let them do this that
parabola so they may they should make
all their decision which is a simply
totally free but since the fool never
tasted of freedom for them it's really
difficult to have the freedom to make on
their decisions in every single way so
there's a lot of side effect for that so
because of the lack of or something
neurology so the only way they can get a
job is something difficult ops which is
most asourian's they don't want to work
in the kind of workplace but North
Koreans are replaced with that yeah it's
having hard time but still I want to
have positive opinion for that exchange
when I arrived in Seoul 2008 like a
South Koreans traded North Koreans more
like alien but because they never heard
about the National refugee is not that
common through the media but over the
time it's 2014 over time there's many
North Koreans are giving a public speech
and the urging a lot of our activities
in different ways and the speciality is
a North Korean women's polka show in
North in South Korea so many ways it's a
help
two North Koreans to get to know North
Koreans more and so it's their hostility
or just prejudice becoming less but we
need have more time to make this gap
more close we need take time thank you
for coming I read an excellent book on
North Korean refugees by Barbara dimeric
it's called nothing to envy it was just
such a revelation for me I think what
surprised me most was after the North
Koreans arrived in South Korea we
Americans think oh now everything is
perfect and it's Disneyland and there
are no more problems and what struck me
was the culture shock that you have
talked about and I was amazed at just
how difficult it is for the North
Koreans to enter into South Korean
society or Western society is there any
way you can see that can facilitate that
you mentioned the TV shows and now
people are starting to have more
awareness but I just was hoping there
was some solution you see that can speed
the process or ease the process for the
North Koreans yeah there's many NGOs
actually trying to help North Korean
people get out of the time there's a lot
but actually they're focusing most
inside North Korea but there's a list
NGOs focus on North Korean refugees
living in South Korea actually they're
also suffering a lot of problems also
there are suffering in terms of human
rights and in terms of finances system
especially it's hard to get job in so
square even university student optical
Azzurri it's not even so screen students
is hard to get a job these days so North
Koreans more having a difficult stance
even they graduate from school
so actually I was think about that
cousin many time like that is exactly
what I wanted to do in the future
mmm because we need to more keep help
hand - snores can refugees because they
are like a mother living in South Korea
right now if they having a hard time
that's a good propaganda for North
Korean regime - nothing living inside
North Korean people like Oh North Korea
a people in Social Security are
suffering blah blah like this so it's a
really good propaganda tool for them so
I wanted North Korean to having a better
life very situation that now so for them
I think need international help
communities of Hope especially like in
terms of English program something
because uh many of my friends especially
when they if someone went America to
study abroad even for six months or one
year after they come back to South Korea
they have an enormous proud of that look
at you know and the oh it's cuz it's
looks good for the resume and that they
can learn English spot it so the chance
is really limited for North Koreans it's
really hard to get to study in abroad in
America especially in English in
speaking English country so I hope if
there's a possibility it's just helping
us go to refugees give them one more
chance to study or to learn something in
the international community then it's
really hope for them alright we're gonna
take one last question
alright thanks for coming today and
sharing your remarkable stories I'm Kent
I'm one of several members of this
community who have actually visited
North Korea as tourists and I wanted to
ask you because I know before making
that decision to go some of us struggle
we think on one hand maybe we're helping
North Korean people because we're coming
from the outside world and giving people
exposure on the other hand
of our money goes to the government so
what do you think as someone who's lived
there and is now working for improvement
of people's lives in North Korea do you
think it's good for foreigners to visit
North Korea or do you think it's bad oh
actually I'm the person who's against
the foreign tourists in to Pyongyang
because some people think well when we
visit the North Korea it's good for them
like oh they they somehow learn about
America by looking something they have
some different ideas but as North Korean
what we learnt from from the
kindergarten exactly we also we see the
media everything through the TV and then
we see a lot of foreigners visiting
North Korea we had the wrong ideas while
the foreigners with respect or
government Allah and then they're like
it's a tear little tear parabola so so
we just fit our culture's the best in
the world attack that's another
propaganda food and knows in coming to
uses so yeah so it's and another way is
you said like a kind of soft policy or
like a hard-line Oh many people I think
a bit fright are sunshine Paris in the
past it didn't worked and then we also
tried hard policy also it didn't work so
I want to have something mixed together
not to go this way or the other way we
need mix but one thing we should real we
should know even though there is a
sentence these days and even though
there's a no help from the outside or
something help a but not scream people
still there's a middle class is raising
in North Korea which means they many
people in North Korea after the famine
they didn't rely on the government
they're earning money by themselves from
the plain market or markets so they
didn't rely on the cabinet totally right
now so in the picture it a star
have a money right now and then we
support the North Korea means support
the regime not the ordinary people yeah
that's my answer
it isn't gentlemen please join me
thanking Hamza